[Musique]
les conclusions sont simples il ya trois
conclusions il faut progressivement
levées se passe vaccinale les courbes
émise par pasteur indique que
normalement dissidents dans la quinzaine
qui vient on devrait être en deçà des
hospitalisation en soins critiques
pour l'ensemble de la france et c'était
un des critères qui avait posé deux
ministres olivier ferrand pour sortir du
pass maximale deuxième préconisations
importante c'est la question du pilotage
le conseil de défense comme lieu de
pilotage ne nous paraît pas le lieu
propice ont fait pas la guerre contre un
virus fait pas la guerre pour la santé
des français donc on demande que le
parlement soit saisi sur ces questions
notamment par l'article 50 1 et puis
qu'on travaille pour l'avenir un lieu
propice de décision qui n'est pas le
conseil de défense et une recommandation
à mes yeux essentielles celle de prendre
soin des 300000 personnes
immunodéprimées des personnes âgées des
personnes isolées dans leur quartier ou
dans leur commune mais aussi des
personnes pour x raisons diverses
raisons souvent la précarité n'ont pas
accès aux réseaux de soins donc il faut
absolument que la caisse d'assurance
maladie puissent les contacts et comme
on le fait sur d'autres vaccinations par
exemple
[Musique]